bien nos preguntan utiliza la
herramienta reflejar para encontrar la
imagen del triángulo x y z si este
triángulo que está aquí x y z tras una
reflexión a través de la línea de igual
a menos x menos 4 muy bien voy a iniciar
activando la herramienta reflejar con
este botón y ya la tengo aquí muy bien
ahora vamos a analizar la línea que nos
están pidiendo es la línea de igual a
menos x menos 4 bueno lo primero que
observo es que esta línea tiene una
pendiente de menos 1 o sea menos x es lo
mismo que menos 1 por x
esta línea tiene pendiente menos 1 así
que lo que voy a hacer es a ver voy a
tratar de ver vamos a mover un poco y
ahora vamos a intentar modificar
pendiente de esta recta y parece que
esta es o sea la pendiente es menos 1
esto es correcto es decir a medida que
avanza 1 en la horizontal avanzó menos 1
en la vertical a medida que avanza 1 en
la horizontal avanzó menos 1 en la
vertical muy bien ahora también
observamos que cuando x vale 0 entonces
es igual a menos 4 quiere decir que esta
línea cruza el eje vertical el eje i
en menos 4
cuando x vale 0 que es este valor que
está aquí lleva al menos 4 este que está
aquí entonces ahora voy a tratar eso de
moverla muy bien entonces ahora ya tengo
la línea de igualdad menos x menos 4
lo siguiente que voy a hacer es ahora
utilizar el botón de reflejar
y parece que vamos muy bien es decir el
punto x que se encontraba a la derecha
de la línea de igual a menos x menos 4
ahora se encuentra a la izquierda y lo
mismo ocurre con los otros puntos veamos
muy bien